et pour parler de la situation en
afrique nous sommes en liaison avec
kalou et magloire kemayou président du
club d'informations africaines
bonjour ou magloire kemayo merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a vu l'afrique subsaharienne
semblait jusque là plutôt épargnée par
le virus force est de constater que ce
n'est plus le cas maintenant comment les
états africains se prépare justement à
faire face aux coronavirus pour
l'instant les états africains montrent
qu'ils sont surpris mais ne sont pas
plus surpris que les autres pays les
pays européens comme la france l'espagne
ou l'italie sont à peu près dans la même
situation
cependant je pense que c'est le grand
moment aujourd'hui de dire à ceux qui
ont une parcelle de pouvoir qu'ils
doivent l'exercer pour empêcher la
pandémie de se propager surtout à la
population de prendre ses
responsabilités et également parce que
ce que l'on voit dans les populations
c'est qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
théories du complot qui circulent et
donne l'impression comme aux débuts du
sida que c'est une invention que c'est
un réel que de toute façon c'est importé
que c'est contre les africains
je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui se
donner les moyens de faire en sorte de
juguler la crise et après on verra
comment est ce qu'on pourra porter les
accusations sur un camp ou un autre
louis camaïeu est ce que les pays
africains sont en mesure de faire face à
cette épidémie
oui je crois qu'ils peuvent ça fait
longtemps aujourd'hui que les pronostics
sur le fait que le sida les dévasté le
continent africain sont passés
n'oublions pas qu'il ya d'autres
maladies qui font beaucoup plus de morts
que le coc u19 qui continue de sévir et
de faire plus de morts dont je pense que
le continent africain poids réussira à
juguler la crise cependant cela ne
dépend pas que de la volonté des gens
cela ne dépend pas que du discours que
l'on tiendra sa dépend également des
actions qui seront menées à la fois par
les autorités par les populations mais
aussi le concours des différents
partenaires qui pourront aider le
continent africain tant au surplace
à partir de l'extérieur a tiré son
épingle du jeu
on va prendre l'exemple du burkina faso
avec avec le premier mort sur le sur le
continent africain en tout cas en
afrique subsaharienne enregistré hier
quatre ministres sont infectés par le
coronavirus et 60 k 64 cas recensés dans
le pays
est ce que le nombre de cas recensés
reflète la réalité c'est difficile à
dire parce que si on avait un outil
statistique fiable cela permettrait de
dire si oui ou non le nombre de cas est
rifflet la réalité du terrain
la première chose que ça reflète sait
déjà que tous ceux qui disaient que le
virus ne peut pas tenir dans la chaleur
se sont trompés vu qu'ils avaient qu'à y
compris dans la région sahélienne où il
fait plutôt chaud on a de nombreux cas
qui sont révélés et donc à partir de
veille quand il s'agit d'être de plus en
plus responsables et de chutes de deux
coups de tenir la conduite qui permet
non pas d'être dans le déni
mais dans un combat efficace contre la
maladie
et c'est le moment pour moi d'avoir
beaucoup de beaucoup de sympathie
d'envoyer toute ma sympathie à toutes
ces personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
bloqués dans les aéroports
soit parce qu'elles viennent de
l'extérieur en allant vers leur pays
soit parce qu'elles sont étrangères et
qu'elles vivent dans un pays où ils sont
protégés comme des vecteurs de cette
maladie dont je pense que c'est c'est
important aujourd'hui d'aller au delà
des discours pour apporter de l'action
concrète et de sortir un coup de la
sinistrose dans laquelle on est au
apporter des réponses qui qui permet aux
gens de trouver des solutions et non pas
d'être dans la peur seulement vous
parliez tout à l'heure de théorie
du complot des populations qui ne
croient pas forcément dans cette
épidémie de coronavirus en afrique
subsaharienne
est ce que les gouvernements africains
font font leur devoir d'information sur
sur la population
les gouvernements font une partie de
leur travail je pense que c'est le
moment pour ces pour ces gouvernements
et surtout pour les gens qui sont à leur
tête de montrer à quel point leur
autorité peut être utile parce que
jusqu'à présent leur autorité
ressemblait plus à de l'eau teocalli sme
cas qu'un service public un service à
leurs populations
c'est le moment pour elle de montrer
qu'elles peuvent être utiles à leurs
populations à médan à endiguer
l'épidémie a arrêté la pandémie qui est
en train de prendre naissance certains
disques dieu au contrôle mais avant d'y
aller gens eux mêmes
et puis les autorités qui ont été élus
ou alors désigné pour répondre à ce
genre de situation et je pense qu'il
faut pas cela très au sérieux même si on
n'a pas de moyens il ya des attitudes
des gestes barrières comme on dit qui
permettent de bloquer et l'épidémie est
de répondre surtout à la menace qu'elle
qu'elle comporte
merci beaucoup il magloire que mayo
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
sur rtl france rappelle et que vous êtes
à président du club de l'information
africain merci beaucoup